We've derived one system of transforming transparency that mostly works. To sum
up all the opaque objects are rendered first, with Z buffering on, blending is
then turned on for the transparent objects that follow. Blending takes extra
time for the GPU to compute, so it's turned on only when needed. Finally, the
transparents objects are sorted by their destins along the view, and are
rendered in back to front order. If the camera or objects are moving, this
sorting has to be done in every frame. This algorithm is in fact with three j s
implements, you make an object transparent by setting its material. There are
two parameters to set. The opacity is the f of value used for blending. You must
also set the transparent parameter to be true. This transparency scheme usually
works fairly well in practice but there are still quite a few problem cases. One
problem is inter penetration. Here's the demo showing one transparent block
moving through the other, give this demo a try. Move the camera around and use
the slider to position the block. The dot on the center of each object is what
is used to measure it's distance along the direction the camera is viewing. Once
you're done with the demo, you'll then answer a question as to what's going
wrong.